come with me to race cars in
[Music]
Vegas our trip begins in Los Angeles at
the AMX Lounge getting a snack hopping
on the plane and landing in Vegas a very
short 35-minute flight and we're here
this is the night before met up with
some friends at a welcome event we got
two Xbox controllers in the theme of the
forsa cover cars and had some really
great desserts the next morning we
hopped on a bus for an hourong ride from
the strip to the Spring Mountain Motor
Resort got a helmet like actual race
helmet super hyped about this oh yeah
ready to go so this is the
break we wasted no time we geared up and
hopped into our first course oh jeez you
were speeding speed
times I'm still very new to track racing
but I get it now this is so freaking
fun the next course we did was a lead
and follow we had an instructor in front
of us and he guided us through this
track I thought I was doing pretty good
until after this run we got in the car
with the professional drivers and they
showed us at full speed what this track
was all about woo oh man that's way
faster than I was
going oh oh my
God this is literally all fun and games
I went from track to sim and it was so
much fun finally getting a chance to
play the new Forza Motorsport let's just
let's just follow the line and be the
best that we can be
oh yeah we're making progress
now I'm glad we went on the Real Track
first before I played this because I
would be a little concerned about my
skills this was so much fun I cannot
wait to play fora when it finally comes
out on October 10th and it was so cool
to get a chance to share this experience
with some of my other Creator friends
dude I'm doing so well I'm having a good
time racing fast cars food fun it's
fantastic are you having fun oh hell
[Music]
yeah I'm sorry I'm having a great time
I'm just having the bestest time ever
I'm having a great time that's great
good to hear it get me out of here thank
you welcomee it this was so much fun hug
thank you to Forza and Xbox for making
this happen I can't wait to actually
play the
game